はい それではよろしくお願いします
早速今日のテーマに入ります
サンガに帰依するっていうことの意味
で 三宝に帰依するっていうのは仏教のね
決まり 基本ですからね
今日はこの帰依するということについて
まあいくらかこの仏教の内容だけ考えてみたいと思います
まず仏教徒になるというね
お釈迦様の教えをね 実践する仏教徒になるっていうことはどういうことかというと
欠かせない条件は仏法僧にブッダ
ダンマ サンガですね まあ帰依することです
それはもう欠かせない条件なんですね
なんか他の宗教と似ているような気がしますけどね
まず神を信じなさいというところから始まりますからね
イスラム教であってもね
こちらは仏法僧に帰依しますということは
もう仏教徒になる もう条件なんですね
帰依と宗教では一般的に言う信仰ではありません
この仏教の帰依ということは
あの宗教でいう信仰とは違います
であえて違う単語使ってますね
サラナンという で 宗教の信仰にはいっぱい別な単語がありますよ
インドの言語では で 他のヒンドゥー教とかはよく使ってますけど
仏教はあえてそれを捨てているんです
捨てて どんな宗教も使ってない
このサラナン帰依という言葉を使っているんです
だからそういうことで
もう神を信仰するということとはかなり違うなものなんですね
だからなかなか大変ですよ
仏教徒になるのは サラナンとは指導を受ける
頼りにする 導いてもらう
育ててもらう 困った時は助けてもらうというニュアンスです
だから この恐れて無条件で信仰するということではなくて
なんか困った時は助けてもらうとかね
教えてもらうとかね という導いてもらうような意味なんですね
三宝はこの上のない導師
指導者として 自分の意思で決める
定めることです それで三宝は私の導師であると
師匠であると自分が決めなくちゃいけないんです
自分の意思で言われてやっても仏教徒になってないんです
この仏教徒にならなくてもいいんじゃないかと言ったっても
この三宝の帰依が体に染くということはものすごく違うんです
ものすごい違います だから我々は生まれつき仏教徒だから
すぐわかりますよ いたって簡単にサンケーしている人かない人かということはわかります
まあベラベラベラ言ってる人はいくらでもいますけどね
サンケーは体に心に宿るある
なんか特別なエネルギーみたいなもんなんです
そういう人々の目つきとすべて違うということですね
それであの三経っていうのは成長発展の開始なんです
あれにもこれにも興味がある
あれこれも信じてみたい
皆 言葉と表現が変わっても
同じ真理を教えているなどを考える一般人は優柔不断です
なんか知識かぶっている人って結構いるでしょうね
まあどんな宗教でもね
まあ言葉が変わっても同じ真理を教えているんだぞとかね
だから私は特定の宗教なんか信仰しないぞとかね
まあ偉そうなことを言ってますけど
優柔不断だけなんです
どんな宗教も同じことをおっしゃっているのかということは
この相当言いづらいんですよ
だって各宗教は学んでみなきゃ
こんなことできるのかい？と
で 一生をかけてキリスト教とか学んでいる専門家でさえも
もうわからない いまだに
神って何ですか？とかね
なんでこんな世界になっているのかとかね
世紀末来るのかいと 来ないのかいと
ずっと議論ばっかりやってるしね
ヒンドゥー教の人々ももう全くわからないんですよ
もういろんな人の教えをパクるだけで
もうなんか だからどんな宗教も同じこと言ってるんだっていうのを軽々しく言うのはね
随分と あの 何ですかね
知識的な言葉ではないんですね
気持ちとしてみんな仲良くしてほしいというならばね
それはそれでまあ気持ちはいいとは思いますけど
まあ私もみんな仲良くしてほしいと思いますけど
その割にはね まあボロクソに宗教のこと批判しますけど
まあと言ってもね ボロクソに言うことは言うんだけど
やっぱりみんな人間としてね
すごくできるだけ仲良くした方がよろしいしね
だからといって考えはいろいろありますからね
そこでこの 例えば日本みたいなね
いろんな信仰がいっぱいある世界ではみんな走り回るんですね
いろんな宗教 新興宗教組織などに
何に走るか どこに行ったらご利益
商売繁盛するのかどうかね
どこに行ったら自分のガンが治ってくれるのかい？とかね
で そんな感じでね 占い師にも走っていったり
だからそれは明らかに優柔不断なんですよ
占い師に頼んだ時点でもう人格は終わりですよ
もう人間じゃないんです
まああまり面白いんだからやってみようかっていうのは
それはいいんですよ ふざけて
まあそれは大した金額でもないんだからね
ちょっと聞いてみようかとかね
で それは構わないんですよ
遊びでやるのは私は全然
もうもう で いろんな宗教で何やってるんですかね
ちょっと見てみようかなとかね
まあそれは構わないんだけど
やっぱりこの占ってそれに頼るとかね
どこか新興組織に入って
それで全ての問題を解決してくれるとか
そういうふうにあちいったりこっちいったりするっていうのは
やっぱり明らかに優柔不断ですよ
この優柔不断っていうのは
人間にとってはすごい危ないんです
仏教は心の成長っていうものを言うんですね
我々は考えることですから
脳細胞っていうね 筋肉も使ってますね
だからこの優柔不断状態っていうのは
脳にもものすごく悪いんです
脳っていうのはビシビシと判断する機械であって
判断できませんって言ったら機能停止なんですね
機能停止するとすごいエネルギー使っている機械だから
これ壊れるんです だから優柔不断でいる人っていうのは
本当に人格的に もう人間としてものすごく役に立たなくなっちゃうんですよ
責任持てなくなっちゃうし
もう管理職とか何もできなくなっちゃうし
で 会社に入ったってもずっと平社員で人生終わってしまっちゃうし
やっぱり我々は毎日毎日いっぱい
一歩進んでいかなくちゃいけないんです
それなら脳がビシビシと判断してくれないと
だからこの瞬時に判断してくれないと困るし
できれば正しい判断してほしいんですね
正しい判断をする前に判断能力身についておいてるんですよ
イチガバチがどうでもいいんだけど
その判断能力は 仏教は正しい判断能力に育ててあげるんです
最初から判断能力がないんだったらどうしますかね
何を育てるんですかね
ですから この優柔不断状態っていうのはかなり良くない
で これは一発でなくなるんですよ
参詣したら 心 精神 智慧の発展を障害する原因ですね
優柔不断っていうのは
心は発展しない 成長しない
智慧が現れてこない 仏法に納得して
ブッダと僧たちの生き方を調べて
道はこれだ この道を歩むのだと決めることは嫌です
だから帰っていうのは一つ何か卒業するような感じなんです
まずブッダの教えを勉強しなくちゃいけない
私はそれをやらせているんです
だから いろんな宗教を比較しながら
ボロクソに宗教に信仰にいろんな冗談も言いながら
それはただ勉強なんです
まあ私は勉強しています
終わってますけど 皆様とご一緒にもう一度考えてみましょうと
これは信仰する以前の話をやっているんです
そこでブッダの教えはいろんな世の中の知識と比較して
あらゆる宗教と比較して勉強したところで
やっぱりブッダの方が真理であると自分が納得いったら
もうある程度で ブッダと法に対しては信仰し
信貴が成り立っていて
それから僧というのは弟子たちですね
お釈迦様はもう何といいますか
真のことというか すごいかっこいいことを教えるかもしれません
けど 誰もやってないんじゃないかと言われるとまずいんですよ
そうすると これ実践して
それなりに豊かに 穏やかに
安らぎになっているのかと
で 調べるんです だから理論は合っている
実践する人々もいる 実践する人々もいろいろ成果を出している
では 私もこれやってみても大丈夫やと
で これからやるぞと決めること
そこで帰依が成立しているんです
だから一つの卒業したっていうような感じなんですね
そう簡単じゃないんです
ですから 他の宗教では
この神道儀式儀礼があるんですよ
イニシエーションセレモニーとか
金がかかりますけど いろいろあるんです
で 水をかぶるとか で それでも神の
何といいますかね まあ誰かになりましたとかね
で 神の仲間になったというならばありがたいんですけど
神の奴隷になったっていう単語を使っているんだからね
情けないんですけどね
だから私なら洗礼する場合はね
両足をロープで結んでね
10 分ぐらい水の中に浸けておきたいんですけど
頭から それで上げてみたら
やっぱり神に連れて行かれたと
ほら 見て 目の前で結果でしょうと言いたいんですけどね
だからそんなもので 心に何の影響あるかどうかよくわかりませんだけど
このカルト的なものは人間っていうのはすごく好きですから
そういういろんな宗教で
このその宗教の信者さんになるために
いくらかのセレモニー儀式っていうのはあるんですね
仏教ではないんです ある学者がね
まあ西洋の学者なんですけど
まあ宗教いわゆるあの比較宗教の専門家で
で 彼がいろんな宗教のことを書いてね
仏教はやっぱりもうどうかな
困ったもんやと 仏教ではね
仏教徒にする方法っていうのはまるっきりないんだと
これを不完全であると
比較宗教を学んだところで
あの方があの方が原始人類石器人のインチキ
というかね このカルトからカルトシステムに仏教は当てはめないんだと
だから何やと私は聞きたいんですけど
仏教でないんです それを我々は自慢にしているんです
で 仏教を学んでいろいろ調べていく上で
自分が精神的に成長して
ああ わかったと やっぱり仏教だと
その納得いく時点で帰依なんです
いわゆる帰依の資格が取っているんです
そういうわけで あの精神的成長がスタートします
帰依が始めたら後でやりますけど
このじゃあ仏法僧に納得しましたと言っても
帰依じゃないんです 私は納得できていますよと言っても
帰依じゃないんです やっぱり正式的に私はこれから自分の人生を仏法僧に導かれて
仏法僧の指導の下で頑張ってみますと
だから仏教徒はには義務があるんです
もうただ私は仏教だと言っただけでは意味がないんです
その日から その人が心を清らかにすることに
人格向上することに 煩悩をなくすことに
日々努力しなくちゃあかんです
だから宿題というか 仕事があるんですね
だからこの仕事をしますという風に自分で決めた時点で仏教徒なんです
はい そうやって自分が仏教と仏法僧に帰依して
生きていると言ったら
なんか人の自由はどうなるのかと
三経は強いられることは不可能ですよ
個が理解する 納得する
信頼することと 個人が自由意志で決めることが必要です
各自で納得することを理解することが必要し
その各自で じゃあ私がやりますと宣言しなくちゃいけないんです
その人が ですから これは自由と関係ないんです
親に知人に言われて帰依するのは構わないが
自分が納得して実践すると決定した時点でのみ帰依が定まります
例えば我々みたいなね
仏教の国の場合は みんなもう仏教徒だからね
それで仏教徒になるかとなれるかと
微妙ですよ 小さい時から仏教に触れて
そのような生き方をしていて
なんか知らないうちにやっぱり仏教であるとみんななんとなくもう決めてしまうんですね
自動的に形式文句は朝から晩まで言ってますから
それは大丈夫ですけど
その時点からその人が
あるんです だから仏教の国ではもう仏教とは
仏教徒はみんな仏教徒であると言ったっても
これは違います 伝統的に仏教ですが
仏教徒になることは各自で自由で行う作業なんです
ややこしいんですね 仏教は
ですから このよくね 我々の国だったら
もう赤ちゃんの時からもう坊さんに会わせたり
いろいろもうすき合わせたり
もう無理やりに礼をさせたり
お経はもう勉強よりも先にお経を覚えさせたり
まあいろいろするんですけど
でも嫌がって逃げる子はないんですね
キリスト教と違って キリスト教の家族では
西洋ではもう嫌よ こんなものはというふうな
まあ逃げている子供たちはね
まあ結構いますけど まあそれは仏教の国々ではないんですね
修行によって預流果に達したならば
信 いわゆる帰依が確立するんです
それで帰依っていうことは
それから信 サッダーというものに変わるんです
帰依が信に変わるんです
信に変わったということは
もうもう確信しましたと
確信 それには悟りの第1のステージに達しなくてはいけないんですね
ということは 皆様に帰依もなくて信仰もない
そんなに怪しいなと言っているような感じがしますけどね
まあ結構大変な作業ですからね
気にしないでください
そういうわけで 帰依っていうのはイコール第一悟りだと思っても構わないんです
預流果に達した人に四つの特色があります
それは経典からの引用ですね
1と2と3の特色は 仏
仏法僧に対する揺らがない信
確信があること その確信って何ぞやというところで
帰依の文句を紹介するんですね
だから 経典 お釈迦様の言葉から推測すると
帰依イコール預流果の悟りなんです
4番目の特色は優れた道徳者であること
これはソータッパディサン言ってにまあずっともう半分以上の経典にそういう定型文句みたいな感じで出てくるんですね
だからあの帰依する時点も仏教を学んで一つの卒業なんです
それで帰依は完了したっていうことは
もう一つ卒業なんです
それはもう悟りに達しているんです
もうこれからもう戻ることもないし
揺らぎも一切ないし まっすぐな解脱を目指して
そういう方々はもう頑張るんです
従って 三帰は仏道入門の第一歩です
仏道に入ろうと思ったら
まず三帰することになっているんです
三帰とは何かと学ぶ必要がありますね
ですから これからこの三帰ってどういうことかとちょっと学んでみましょう
ややこしくなりますけど
まあ三位一体ということですね
まあこれパクった言葉だから
ちょっとはてなマークも入れちゃったんです
私が作った単語じゃないんです
シッダッタ・ゴータマという人物に頼るのではなく
正覚者 サンマサンブッダである釈迦牟尼仏陀に帰依するんです
仏法僧の第一ブッダですね
我々は ある シッダッタ・ゴータマという名前があった
あの今亡くなられている人物に頼って帰依しているわけじゃないんです
正覚者に帰依しているんです
正覚者である釈迦牟尼仏陀に
何が違うんですかね 結構違います
シッダッタ・ゴータマっていうのはスッドーダナ王子の息子で
スッドーダナの息子でしょ
まだ打ったことはない
そんな大きい国でもなかったしね
かなり昔の話ね しかし
そのシッダールタ・ゴータマという人が修行して悟ったんです
その時点からブッダというふうな
このコモンナウン を使ったんです
自分に対して シッダールタ・ゴータマ菩薩が悟りに達したからブッダ
如来と呼ばれるんです
だから ある人が悟らないとダメなんですよ
だから人類初めてシッダールタ・ゴータマという方が
菩薩が悟りに達したんです
それで如来というんですね
ブッダというんです 証覚者になったことで
ブッダとして敬の対象になるんです
ですから 仏教徒の方々は
ある人に頼って依存しているわけじゃないんです
証覚者になった方に敬しているんです
解脱を完了した方に敬しているんです
なんかそこっぽい例えで考えてみましょうか
田中さんという人がいるんですね
まあこちらではないと思ってください
いたら困ります で 別に田中さんに尊敬する必要はないでしょ
しかし その田中さんが
免許を取っている医者なんですね
それで私は田中先生って言うんです
頼りにするんです 病気になると
というわけで 田中さんという人なら誰でもいいわけじゃなくて
医師免許を取って医者免許を取っているかないかっていうことなんです
だから医者には先生と言いながらも
もう頼りになる 田中さんであろうか
もう何さんであろうか
もうそれは関係ないんです
そういうことで ゴータマもうシッダールタ・ゴータマという菩薩がやっぱりこの資格を取ったんですね
ブッダになったっていう
悟ったっていう それでそのブッダに敬する
だから単語はものすごく厳しく
決して あのゴータマさんに敬しますという風に出ていないんです
パーリ語で というわけで
証覚は資格です  2番目法
悟りの智慧で発見して語られた真理が法です
この法っていうのは お釈迦様が真理を発見して悟りに達して
その真理は何なのかと語ったんですね
人が言うことすべて法じゃないんです
法を学び 実践することで人は解脱に達するんです
それで このブッダに語られた教えは
実践してみると 学んで実践してみると
その人も悟りに達するんです
そういうすごい強力な
パワフルな教えだけ法なんです
ブッダが喋るすべて法というわけじゃないんです
しかし お釈迦様もおっしゃってますけど
悟ったその時点から無駄話は一切しないだろうと
お釈迦様は悟った その時点から涅槃に入られた瞬間まで
その間で語った言葉なら
すべて人々のためになる
人々を解脱に導く言葉であるとは説かれてますけど
まあよく我々現代人はよくわかりませんだからね
我々知っているのは残されている経典だけなんですね
その残されている経典の中
経典を見てみると お釈迦様が面白いことを何も言ってないみたいで
そんなことばかり喋ってたら結構もう嫌われるものになるんではないかなという感じで
全部このすごい厳しく
この真理を分析しながら
心を分析しながら 人の生き方を分析しながら
解脱に達する道を教えているんですね
だからその法っていうのは結構魔力があるんですよ
学ぶと心が変わるんです
学んだだけで 理解しただけで
まあ結構立派な人間に
なんか何か微妙に変わっていくんです
人の心を変える言葉といえば
ブッダの言葉は全部そうなんです
すごい力があるんです
それがなんでこの魔力が入ったんですかね
お釈迦様は悟ったんだからなんです
私たちの言葉には全然魔力でありますけど
みんな逃げちゃいますからね
みんな追い出す魔力はあるんだけど
みんなの人格を向上する魔力はなかなかないんです
最高の真理は解脱涅槃のみです
そこでお釈迦様の真理ね
たくさん語ったんだけど
まあ真理 4つですからね
空・渋・滅・道というんですけど
その中でも一番目的は解脱なんですね
輪廻を脱出して解脱すること
ですから 解脱そのもの
悟りそのものが最小の一番トップの真理です
それが法本物です 悟りと悟りに達する道なので
法に帰します なんで法に帰しますかというと
これが悟りであり 同時に悟りに達する道でもあります
なんでブッダに帰しますかというと
ブッダが悟ったんだから
なんで法に帰しますかというと
これは悟りと悟りに達する道ですから
人の教えは 悟りであり
悟りへの道であるならば
帰すべき法という資格を取ってます
だからお釈迦様も一人の人間でしたから
一人の人間は喋るんですよ
人間喋ることに帰しちゃうと
もうたまったもんじゃないんですよ
もう人が言うことを真面目にね
信じちゃうとね どうなるのかと
だからどうぞ勝手に喋ってください
信頼しませんよっていうのはね
まあ我々の普通立場でしょ
政治家の話みたいにね
随分饒舌で達者で喋りますけど
中身はゼロですね だから聞いて
あ そうかとみんな出ていくんです
だからまあ 一般人の話し方
喋り方 喋りはそんなもんでしょうに
しかし お釈迦様は人間でしたけど
お釈迦様の言葉は違うんですね
その言葉が悟りをあらわにする
解脱を発表する その方法も発表する言葉
だからそれに帰します
で  3番目 僧サンガ 誰かさんの弟子ということで尊敬に帰することに値しないんです
サンガというのはブッダの弟子ですからね
では帰しましょうとは
それは値しません 世尊の弟子
仏弟子がその教えを実践して悟りに達するんです
そこでお釈迦様の弟子たちも
弟子になったのは学ぶためでしょ
だから学んで実践するんですよ
学んで実践して悟りに達するんですよ
それで帰値する資格持ちです
また資格取ってるんです
見てください お釈迦様も資格取らなくちゃいけないんです
教えにもその資格がなければダメです
僧にも資格が必要です
帰依の対象になる僧宝になります
なんでこの宝という単語を使ってますかね
これあえて入れてるんですよ
この仏法僧は宝なんですね
三宝なんです 人間にこの三つを通して
この上のない幸福になれるんです
他誰に頼ったっても大したことはないんです
全面的に医者に頼っていたんだからといって
病気から解放されるわけじゃないんです
政治家を徹底的に信仰しているんだからといって
国は豊かになるわけないんです
みんな自分の約束を果たせないんです
学校の教師は子供たちを教えてあげて育てるのは仕事ですけど
まあそこそこでしょ 仕事は
誰も人間っていうのは自分
その約束を果たしてないんですね
まあそこそこなんとか頑張ってるだけ
しかし 仏法僧に帰依するとそうではないんです
この仏法僧はちゃんと仕事するんです
ちゃんと人々を導くんです
言う通りになれば 確実に百パーセント幸福になります
紛れもなく 揺らぎなく
確実に幸福になります
そこはもう断言的に決定しているんだから
宝という漢字使っている
宝ってラタナっていう
その聖なる弟子たちにも
他人に教えることも指導することもできるんです
それでお釈迦様の弟子たちも資格を取るんですね
悟るんですよ 悟ってから
その方々にも教えてあげることできるでしょうに
指導することはできるでしょうに
それでお釈迦様も教えてあげたり
指導したりする 弟子たちも同じことを教えたり指導したりする
何を教えるかというと
解脱を教える 解脱へ指導する
それで三宝になるんです
だから三位一体なんです
解脱涅槃を中心にして
仏法僧というシステムが成り立ちます
で これでチャートで書きましたけど
仏法僧っていうのは一つなんですね
結局 何に一つの輪になってますけど
これ解脱という大きな輪っかの中に仏法僧があるんです
というわけで 正しく言えば三位一体は仏教なんです
三位一体にというキリスト教の言葉なんですけど
いまだに議論なんです
どういうふうに説明すればいいかとかね
どこかなと ある日 誰かさんがいきなり思い出しちゃったんです
それは三 一体じゃないかなとかね
勝手なんですけど いまだにそこは最終結論は出てないんです
議論ばっかしで 三経は三つでありつつも一つで一つも一つでもあるのです
三経は三つでありながら一つです
これは解脱のへのブループリントなんです
修行者にとって三経は解脱への青写真なのです
えーと 指導通りに それちょっと間違ってますけど
指導通りに実践して苦しみを乗り越えるんです
三経は指導するんです
三経は案内するんです
三経はツアーガイドなんです
ツアーガイドがないとね
英語も喋れませんだからね
外国旅行なんかできないでしょう
外国旅行のところか もう日本の国内旅行も結構ツアーガイドがいてうるさい
あれはうるさいんだけどね
で ちゃんと旅行させて元に戻してくれるんです
ですから 三経っていうのは解脱へのツアーガイドなんです
それなしに悟れるとありえないんです
それなく仏教徒であると
もう何言ってるんですかね
ありえないんです はい
それから三法の内容は何なのかと
さらに見ましょう あの
これは私はかなり手抜きしました
もうあの 皆様 かなりの方々はもう半分以上の方々は暗記していると思いますね
あのイティピソーバガワーアラハンサマーサンブッドーヴィッチャーチャラナサンパンノスガトーローカヴィドゥアヌッ ఎవロープリサダンマサーラティー
サッターデーヴァマヌッサナンブッドーバガヴァーというお釈迦様の能力は９つあるんです
まあ９つと言ったっても悟ったことなんですね
しかし ブッダの悟りと弟子たちの悟りの場合は能力の差があるんです
最初に 発見したんだから
すごい経験があるんですね
それであのテキストとかあるんだから
この言葉の９つの言葉の意味をちょっと参照して読んでみてください
これまあ今私は言い出しちゃうと
まあかなり遅れると思います
アラハン お釈迦様が阿羅漢である
いわゆる悟った方でサマーサンブッダの学者である
アラハンという単語はそこでまあまあ悟ったって意味なんですけど
すべて煩悩をなくって資格を取ったって意味なんです
アラハンという場合は
本当の現代日本語で言えば資格を取っているんだと
どんな資格というと 煩悩をなくして悟りに達しましたという
サマーサンブッダっていうのは
これが誰の指導もなく
完全見事に自分一人で発見しましたっていう意味で
ブッダだけサマーサンブッダなんです
他の弟子たちは いくら優れた阿羅漢であっても阿羅漢なんです
サマーサンブッダではないんです
お釈迦様の指導ですからね
ですから サマーサンブッダは人類の一人しか存在しないんです
で 方法ですね それの文章はソアカートバガヴァタダンモーサンディッティクアカーリクという文章なんです
これは一貫して経典にずっとどこでもあるんです
法に帰依するとは ソアカートバガヴァタダンモーということは納得いくことやと
ソアカートというのは正しく説かれている
サンディッティクというのは目の前で結果を出してくれる
アカーリクっていうのは時代遅れにはなりません
2600年前で説かれたんだからといって
現代人に今携帯依存症の病気の連中に合わないとか
そんなのはありえません
これからもいくら科学発展しても
ブッダの真理はそのまま変わらないんです
それはものすごいことなんです
それはカーリコという
エイヒパッシコ 隠すもの何もない
あんた調べなさいよ 誰にでも堂々と言えます
世界一の天才の人 あんた調べなさい
何か欠点でもあるのかい？と
どうぞどうぞご自由に
と 密教はないんです お前に教えてあげませんよとかね
はないんです サンディョーカリコ
エイヒパッシコ オーパナイコー
オーパナイコーっていうのは
学ぶ人は必ず日々成長していくんで
これをストップできないんです
仏教を学んで 例えば五戒ぐらいでも守ってやろうと思ってやってみてください
日々成長していくんです
摩訶不思議に自分の人格がどんどんうまくいって
幸せになっていくんですよ
これは誰にもストップできません
まあ五戒嫌なら 例えば慈悲の瞑想でも
じゃあ毎日十五分 十五分とかね
朝十五分 夜午後十五分とか三十分ぐらいやってみてください
どうなるのかと 確実に人が成長していくんです
心がどんどん良くなっていくんです
精神的な病気はみるみるうちのうち閉じていくんです
それはオーパナイコーと言うんです
それからパッチャッタングエリタブー
あくまでも個人個人で理解するものです
それはこの強い仕入れてわかるものじゃない
キリスト教みたいに イスラム教みたいに鉄砲を持って機関銃を持って原子爆弾を持って浸透させることは不可能です
三番目 そうほう それはスパティパンノー
バゴトサーカサンゴーという
ちょっと文章は長いんです
長いんだけど 意味は明確の明確です
スパティパンノーっていうのは
正しく道に入って実践しているんだよという
いわゆる仏道を実践しています
セプティパンノーバゴト
だから資格なんです ウジュパティパンノ
仏道とは八正道なんです
それはまっしぐら 涅槃を目指している一番短い直線なんです
微妙にも曲がってないんです
八正道は だからウジュパティパンノ
それからニャーヤパティパンノ
ニャーヤっていうのはまた八正道に使う言葉で
智慧に達する道である
それからサーミーチパティパンノ
サーミーチっていうのは
いわゆる聖なる境地 聖なる境地を目指して頑張っている人々
涅槃解脱を目的にして目指して説かれているのです
それでブッダに来る 法に帰依する
僧に帰依するといっても
このテキストを見ると
お釈迦様に説かれた 一箇所じゃなくて
もうどんな経典を開けてみても
大体そういう帰依信仰など入っているところで
必ずこのフレーズは出てくるんです
で この中身を見ると 解脱という一言葉にを中心にして語られているんです
お釈迦様はあれを自画自賛しているんじゃないんです
私はこの上ない人々を導く能力がありますよとかね
この上ない師匠でしょうとかね
徳に満たしてますよと
バカっていうのはそういうことですよ
あれは自慢じゃないんです
あれは悟りを語っているんです
はい 今日のテーマは僧に帰依するとはどういうことかというテーマなんですね
やっとテーマに入りました
はい 僧に帰依するというのは
パーリ語でサンガンサラナンガッチャミって文章になります
で 意味 2つぐらいに分けて説明します
第一 僧というのは聖者のことなんです
あの僧の帰依する文章の中で
スッピティパンのバーゴトサーガサンゴという文章の中でこういう文章があります
ヤディダンチャッターリプリセヨガニ
世尊の弟子とは すなわち四僧
いわゆる 4つのペア アッタプリセプッガラ 8
種類の人格者なのです
人格者でいえば 8種類ですけど
これペアでペアで取ると4つですね
4つのペアでできている8人の人格者のことを僧と言うんです
エーサバーゴトサーヴァカサンゴ
世尊の弟子たちはこのようなものですというふうに帰依するんです
ただのただ者じゃないんだよと
導いてもらわなくては
教えてもらわなくてはというふうに帰依するんです
要するに一般人ではないんです
僧というのは一般人ではありません
はい それから四法八配の説明に行きます
あの四法八配っていうのは
一応専門的に訳するときに使う単語で
まあただペア 4つのペアということなんですね
うん ペアの4つ フォーペアですから
あの四人に8人になります 1
番目のペアはソーターパッティマッグソーターパッティパレ 1
預流道預流果 預流道とは
聖覇修道のこと 流れに入りましたと
流れっていうのは涅槃に流れる流れですね
解脱の流れがあって それに入っちゃったと
流れに入ったらもう流れていくんです
流れに入った人は第一悟りに達したというんですね
それで悟りの悟りに達するために修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
解脱を目指して修行を始めたら
もう預流道になっているんですね
そこで結果出したら預流果になっているんです
それからサカダーミマッゴサカダーミパレ 3
と4 一来道一来果というんですね
まあこんな感じでは全然なんか意味が出てこないんですけど
欲界に転生するのは一回だけです
それで修行して悟りの流れに飛び込む
飛び込んでさらに進んだらもうステップがあるんです
2番目 悟りの流れに飛び込んで預流果になった人がさらに修行する間は一来道というんです
それで 2番目のバリアーを通したら一来果というんです
一来果というのは その人がまだ完全悟ってないんです
また 4分の2です もし途中で亡くなったとしましょう
寿命が終わっちゃって
預流果の人が寿命が終わって亡くなっても
輪廻転生しますけど たとえ輪廻転生したっても
この俗世間に戻るのはたった一回だけ
まず戻らないでしょう
天界とかどこかに梵天とかで生まれますけど
もし万が一天界か人間界に生まれても
それっきりで悟ります
人間で生まれてもものすごい違うんですよ
赤ちゃんの時から人格は
世の中の価値観を一つも認めません
さっさと物事をわかるところ
辞退辞退になった時点で修行して悟り達するんです
それですから この一来果と言うんですね
次はアナガーミマガ アナガーミパレ
不還道 不還果というふうに日本訳するんですね
それでさらに修行すると
3番目のバリアがあるんですね
それは自動的に進むんですよ
修行したらそんなに 1番目道に飛び込むほど難しくないんです
まあ瞑想はいろいろやり方変わりますけど
で 結果出ないというふうに考える必要はないんです
不還道 不還果っていうのは
この 3番目のバリアー通しちゃうと
不還というのは戻ってこないんです
例えば この世の中で人間一人が 3番目の悟りに達したとしましょう
その人亡くなったら もうこれっきり
もう我々と関係ないんです
まあ聖者たちがだけ生まれる梵天界がありまして
そちらに生まれるんです
戻らないんです そこで悟りに達して涅槃に入るんです
次のペアは阿羅漢道 阿羅漢果と言うんですね
アラハッタマガ アラハッタパラナ
最終解脱に達しているんですね
4番目のステップで終了
涅槃に入ります 死後 涅槃になります
我々の師匠になるのは
指導者になるのは 頼りになるのは以上の 8種類の聖者なんです
だから 僧に帰依するといっても
我々は悟りを経験している先輩指導者に教えてくれる方々に帰依しているんです
はい まあこれで一段落終わりました
時間が余ってるんだから
いろいろ この僧に帰依する文章の中でずっと使っている単語はサーヴァカサンゴという言葉なんですね
サーヴァカっていうのは弟子という意味で
サンガはコミュニティという意味なんですね
サーヴァカは弟子で聖徒ということ
で サンガは集い グループコミュニティソサエティという
みんなこの自我張らない
自我がないんだからね
悟ってるんだだからね
だからこれはたとえあの海に例えてありましてね
いろんな川からね 水に海に水が流れるんですね
一旦流れたら 種類の塩であって
どんな川の水かよくわからないんですね
海を調べている隅田川の水を見つかりましょうとかね
は不可能です そのように人間は個人差があるんだけど
仏弟子になって資格を取った時点で単純な仏弟子であって
だから一つまとめて考えなくちゃあかんですね
海という感じで だからサンガというんです
ものすごい精密な言葉なんですね
悟りに達したらもうサンガです
もう個人ではありません
荒川に水が流れていて
あの海にいるところ 何と言うんでしょうか
河口 で 河口のところまで荒川なんですよ
そこで入ってしまったら
もう海 もうわからない
もう個人差が消えちゃったんです
ですから サーヴァカがサンガにならなくちゃいけないんです
サーヴァカというのは弟子
聖徒でしょ？聖徒が頑張ってサンガにならなくちゃいけないんです
だから あの経典でサーヴァカサンゴ
サーヴァカサンゴ サーヴァカサンゴとずっとスパティパンのバガヴァとサーヴァカサンゴ
ウジュパティパンのバガヴァとサーヴァカサンゴ
それはリピートするんですよ
ニャーヤパティパンのバガヴァとサーヴァカサンゴ
サーミーチパティパンのバガヴァとサーヴァカサンゴ
ヤディダン スナワチ チャッターリ
プリュスユガーニ アッチャ
プリュスプッガラ それからもう一度
エースバガヴァとサーヴァカサンゴ
派手に強調するんですよ
サーヴァカサンゴという単語
なかなかこの仏教を学んでいる人々も
このテーラワーダの人も
そういう単語のすごい意味があるんだということを誰もあんまり気にしていないんです
はい この場合は出家 在家という区別はないんです
ないようです 悟ったらサンガです
在家も悟りに達したら
家に値するサンガです
仏法も説法も指導もできます
だから僧尼戒するといったっても
その中に在家も入られますよ
資格取っちゃえば 論理上そうなるが
現実的には在家の各者たちは出家サンガに尊敬しているんです
ブッダの時代でも 在家の方々
女性も男性も結構悟りに達していたんですよ
在家の方々は最終阿羅漢家にはなれないんです
在家でいる限りは しかし
１  2  3 まではいけます
で 私もサンガ出そうとか威張ることはない
だって自我がないんだからね
威張ることはないんです
出家サンガにはちゃんと礼もする
お布施もする お世話もしてあげる
それをしますが 本当は家に値する
そうなんです その在家の方々も
出家のお坊さんたちが
この人にちょっと教えてあげた方がいいんじゃないかなとわかったら教えてあげるんです
あんたこういう風に修行しなさいとかね
これはこういう風に理解しなさいとか教えてあげるんだけど
威張ることはないんです
それから礼をするんです
頑張ってくださいと あのタイで昔読んだテキストなんですけど
ある女性がね 瞑想指導して
あるお坊さんが そのお坊さんのところに出家しているお坊さんたちが 200人
300人ぐらい集まるんです
あのおばさまがもう在家で
一応八回十回守ってますけど
在家であってもね で 彼女がドカンとでっかい椅子に座って
みんなにお坊さんたちにも教えてあげたり
女性の方々に教えてあげたりしてやってますけど
それで後でお坊さんたちにちゃんと頭を下げて礼もするんです
そういう不思議な世界なんです
はい 帰依の定型文があります
経典ではエーサーハンバガワンタンゴートマンサランガッチャーミダンマンチャビクサンガンチャウパーサカンメバワンゴートモダレートゥアッジャタッゲーパヌペタンサランガタンという
文章が出てくるんです
それはまあもう回でも回でも数えれば見つかるんです
その文章は このような私は尊師ゴートマに帰依します
法と比丘サンガに帰依します
今日から死ぬまで 私は在家信徒であることをご理解してくださいと
認めてくださいじゃないんです
お釈迦様 今日から私は在家信者ですと自分で宣伝するんです
で 経典の場合はちゃんとお釈迦様の名前を入れてるんですね
ブッダンサランガッチャーミではなくて
この場合はゴートマブッダンサランガッチャーミになるんです
これはお釈迦様がいる時はそうなるんです
いつでもお釈迦様から直々教えてもらうでしょ
教えてもらうとどんどん頭が晴れてきて
仏教に対して誤解 全部取れちゃって晴れちゃって
わかりましたと 目が見えない人に目が現れたように
暗闇で灯火を出したように
隠したものを開いてくれたように
お釈迦様が教えてくれましたと
これで帰依を表現するんですよ
アンダカーレテーランパッジョーティ
暗闇の時は灯りを灯けてくれたようなことやと
自分の暗闇にお釈迦様が灯りを灯けてくれたと
チャックマントルーパニダッキンティーという目がある人にはいろんなものを見えるように
お釈迦様はアネーカパーリヤナタターガトダンマンデーシと
お釈迦様は結構工夫して教えてくれたと
エーサーハン そういう私が
いわゆる教えられていただいた私が
ゴートマブッダに帰依します
法にもサンガにも帰依します
今日から私は在家でいいですよ
お釈迦様に報告するんです
それが経典に出てくる定型文句なんです
仏教は組織化になっていくと
いわゆるどんどんどんどん人がね
10人 20人入っちゃうと
一つ組織になっちゃいますから
これはお釈迦様の場合はもう 3ヶ月間経たないうちに
もう 61 人も 60 人もなっちゃったんだから
かなりスピードで あまりにもスピードが速いんだから
批判まで受けちゃったしね
ものすごい勢いで人々は仏教徒になったり
誘ったりするんです 食事になって
すぐまた二ヶ月とかの間でも1000人
他の宗教の人々 みんなそのままお釈迦様仏教徒にしてしまっちゃったんです
そういうわけで どんどんこの組織化になっていくんですね
自動的に しかし お釈迦様は直々だったらそのまま弟子でしょ
私は出家 あ いいよ 出家したい
いいよと それ一言葉で出家なんです
いいよと言わない まあ頑張ってくださいと
それで出家比丘なんです
それでお釈迦様は直々ならそうなんですけど
お釈迦様の弟子から話を聞いて
仏教に興味を持って三帰をして
お坊さん 私も出家したいんだけどって言ったら
このお坊さんどうしますかね
まあいいよって言えないでしょうね
それはお釈迦様の権威だから
まあいいですよ 頑張ってくださいと
そうすると このお坊さんたちが連れて行くんです
お釈迦様のところに お釈迦様はまあ弟子はもう10人ぐらい
もう遠くから連れてきたんですけど 10
人も出家したいと言ってるんですよと
ああ いいんじゃないかと
はい それで終わり でもこれで困ります
出家したい人と師匠が
50キロ  100キロ  200キロ
400キロ 遠くから歩いて行っていて
たまったもんじゃないんですよ
なのでお釈迦様も考えたね
これがこの弟子たちにとってはもうもうすごい苦しみやと
みんな遠くからもう何ヶ月もかけて私を追っかけてこなくちゃ
お釈迦様も動いているんだから大変ですよ
両方同じ方向に動かなればなかなか会えなくなっちゃうんですよ
それでお釈迦様がそれぞれの弟子たちにも出家認めなさいと教えたんです
出家と比丘戒を認めなくてはいけなくなったんですね
初期の出家と比丘戒は
祈願者にブッダンサラナンガッチャーミ
ダンマンサラナンガッチャーミ
サンガンサラナンガッチャーミと3回唱えさせることで完了です
お釈迦様は何でも簡単に済もうと思っちゃいますよ
でもそううまくいかなかったんです
最初は戒律もそんなのは常識だろうと思って定めてなかったんです
できるだけ人生は簡単で
さっさと修行して当たればいいやという感じでしたけどね
人間はだらしないんだから
そううまくいかないんですね
最初はブッダンサラナンガッチャーミという文章を3回唱えたら出家であって比丘なんです
後 皆の消えする定型文句になりました
それでは後で困るということで
子供まで出家しちゃうんですね
子供は子供だから もうちょっとどうかなということもあったんですね
一人前で扱うのはちょっと良くないと
そういうことで まあ子供はまあそこそこ見習いで
まあ遊びながら 間違いもあったっても
まあまあ ちょっと ちょっとやめなさいよとかね
まあ子供の場合そうでしょうに
そうやってやっぱり子供は大人になるまで面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないんですね
その人も一人前の出家と言っちゃうと
あの権利平等になっちゃうんですね
権利平等になっちゃって
あんた何やってるのかと言えなくなっちゃう
それで沙弥出家も決めなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
沙弥出家と比丘出家と 2つ
それで分けちゃったんです
サンケイ唱えることで沙弥出家
それは皆様が唱えたってもダメなんです
それで私たち比丘がちゃんと三経を手渡す
手渡しするような感じで与えるんです
ちょっと厳しい決まりなんです
一旦皆様は今日三経唱えて
明日もうイスラム教になったってもね
別に誰も気にしませんだけど
ああいう風に仏法僧の力をもって三帰与えたら結構厳しいんです
決まりは 今 このブッダンサラナンガッチャーミっていうことは
仏教徒みんなまあ朝晩唱える三経文句に定型文句になっているんです
このブッダンサラナンガッチャーミっていうのは面白くて
なんかいろいろ神秘的な意味を作ろうかなと思っている場合もあります
あの あるバラモンがお釈迦様にあなたはバラモンか何者かと質問してね
あんた生まれは何や？とかね
家は何や？とか言ったら
お釈迦様は聞くなよと言ったの
悪い 道徳を聞きなさいよ
能力聞きなさいよ ったらもうもう結構早漏になりましたけど
そこでこの あなたサーヴィッティンサーヴィサーヴィッティということを知ってますか？とか
このサーヴィッティ知ってるならばバラモン人であるっていう風にこの人が認定したいんですね
このサーヴィッティはパーリ語でサンスクリットになってくるとサーヴィクトリーなんですね
サーヴィクトリーっていうのは正しく作った産業って意味なんです
このヴェーダ聖典 いわゆるヴェーダっていうのは
この仙人たちの耳元で神が言ったそうです
で 神に聞いたことが 仙人たちが８人の仙人たちが文章化
詩にしたんです という伝説がありまして
お釈迦様はその伝説を認めません
だからヴェーダ聖典を読んでみるとだらしないのもいいところなんです
こんなのは神が言うのかい？と
神学聖書と同じなんです
どこかのアホが しかし
聖約聖書よりも頭のいい詩人たちが
文学能力に優れていた詩人たちが作った文学作品のようなもんなんですね
ただ雨を歌っている 雷に歌を作る
そんなもんなんです そのヴェーダ聖典が始まる時は
この火を讃える 行が三つあるんです
繰り返しですけど アグニミレブロヒタムという
家の指導者というか 主人は火であると
これ詩でしょ 家の主人は火といったら人間の文化のことなんです
家っていうのはちゃんと台所で火を焚いてますね
ということは みんな生きてるんですね
料理して食べてるんですね
だから火は我々に命を与えているんです
だって米は食べられないしね
もう食べられますけど
お腹が壊すしね 十分栄養取れないし
それで火火を通していただくとご飯になっているんですね
これで命 そういうわけである詩人が
やっぱり家の主人は火であると文章を作っちゃったんです
これがヴェーダ聖典の冒頭の行なんです
それにサーヴィトリーというんです
それでアグニミレプロヒタムというチャンダス
この詩の形式がありまして
その同じ形式でブッダンサラナンガッチャーミという文章できているんです
そこで同じ行繰り返し
回向じゃなくてダンマンサラナンガッチャーミサンガンサラナンガッチャーミと
この詩の場合はこの文字を計算する方法がありまして
全部トーンティフォースラブという風になるんですね
だからサーウィトリチャンダスの最高な聖なるサーウィトリはブッダンサラナンガッチャーミというミッスであるという風に
まあとにかくどう考えても面白いことは面白いので
ブッダンサラナンガッチャーミっていうのはインドにあった巨大な宗教の
この詩の作り方をそのまま取って作られているということはね
いわゆるヴェーダ聖典は最初からバカにしているんです
火は人類の魂であるということと
小学者を指導者にしまっている
そういう意味が違うでしょう
バカにしてます だからまあ
このサンケーのまあ ちょっとした裏話はそれで終了します
で あれはあのブッダンサラナンガッチャーミダンマンサラナンガッチャーミと
一応節はあります このサーヴァカサンゴという言葉の次
我々勉強するのはビックスサンゴ
サーヴァカサンガと同時にビックスサンガという言葉もあります
ビクとは出家のことです
釈尊出家弟子 出家比丘弟子
サイケ弟子というランクになります
ランクがあります 一応そこでサーヴァカサンゴといえば
お釈迦様の弟子で悟りに達したサンガであって
ビクサンガといえば出家した人々
ちょっと条件厳しい その方々には
お釈迦様の命令にも完全に従わなくちゃいけないので
再婚にある自由はないんです
最近の方は お釈迦様の畑の仕事がありますから
ここら辺で失礼しますとへっちゃらに出て行くんです
その一言も我々には言えないんです
お釈迦様説法するならば
お釈迦様ちょっと用事が出ましたの
それは禁止なんです 説法終わるまで
そのままいなくちゃいかんです
いろいろものすごい厳しいんです
そういう出家した人に比丘と言うんですね
なぜ比丘かというと 托鉢で生計を立てているんですね
生計と言っても食べるものだけですけどね
食べるものとも 衣がボロボロになっちゃったら
何か拾って使う 特に食べ物は毎日必要ですから
それは托鉢でいただくということで比丘と言うんです
比丘もサンガにならなくちゃいけないんです
比丘だけでは困ります
どうやってサンガになるのかというと
修行して悟りに達しなくちゃいけないんです
そこで困っちゃったんですね
比丘たちは大勢たくさんいるし
みんな悟ってるわけじゃないし
これから修行して悟りますからね
修行するために出家するんだから
それでまああなた方も一応サンガとして認めましょうという
あの 認めるんですね いわゆる資格というよりも
法令で条例で認めてくれるという
ということで サンモティサンガというんですね
バイザコンセントオブザブッダ
いわゆるお釈迦様の認定によりサンガである
資格はそれから取りなさいよと
というわけで サンモティ
世間はサンガとして認めても構わない
出家した人々を しかし比丘は合法的にサンガになるためには４人集めなくちゃいけないんです ４
人が一つその意見に全く異論なく達しなくちゃいけないです
そこでこの真似事するの
悟った世界はどんなものかと
異論はない 個人はない
個人は存在しない 個人で威張ることは不可能
みんな会員は全く同じ
何か決めるならば 千人一致で決めなくちゃいけないと
そうやってこの悟った世界の模型というかね
まあそこは頑張ってるんですね
比丘たちは 悟った世界はこんなものやと
ちょっと模型みたいな
いろんな何か作り物で見せているような感じで
しかし それでは困りますから
一人一人が修行して悟りに達しなくちゃいけないんです
悟りに達したらもう断言サンガなんです
もう自我が消えてしまったんです
そういうわけで ランクが分かれちゃったんですね
出家弟子と在家弟子 出家弟子の中で資格を取っている本物のサンガもいるし
その中でただまあ仮免許のサンガもいるし
仮免許のサンガは免許を取らなくちゃいけないんです
在家サンガの場合は悟りに達したサンガもいるし
まだ修行している三帰の信者さんもいるし
在家の方々は三帰をいただいて
仏弟子として頑張ってますけど
仮免許はないんです そういうことでランクがありますね
ですから 出家は在家の先輩になるんです
そういうわけで 出家は在家の先輩
もうランクといってもただ先輩後輩ぐらいの差なんです
それから礼ということが出てくるんですね
仏教は行儀は厳しいんですね
だらしない生き方は認めないんです
いつでも行儀作法 歩くとき
座るとき しゃべるとき
全部すごい品格よくやりなさいと
すべて厳しく決まっているんです
だから礼というものがあります
出家は釈尊と先輩の出家に礼をする
出家している我々は お釈迦様と先輩の出家に礼をするんです
在家は釈尊と出家に礼をするんです
礼をすること これワンダリですね
と帰依をすること サラナンガッチャティは同じ行為ではない
あの出家に礼をしたんだからといって
その人に帰依しているという意味じゃないんです
礼は人間同士で 親子の間でも行う普通の行儀作法ですよ
だから あるお坊様に礼をしたんだから
そのお坊様を帰依しなくちゃいけないとかはないんです
帰依するのはサンガに帰依するんです
俗世間の礼の仕方は仏教は気にしません
あの礼儀正しさっていうのは
まあ社会にいろいろありますけどね
握手するか お辞儀をするか
もう抱きしめるか いろいろありますけどね
あまり仏教は気にしません
しかし 社会常識に従って
在家は世間の礼のしきたりにも従うんです
在家は危ないんだから
社会のしきたりも守ってくださいと
しかし それはいい加減でもう表面でいいんやと
本物の礼は違いますよと教えているんです
仏教は一 智慧 二 道徳 三
生まれという順にするんです
智慧がある人は目上で礼をしなくちゃいけない
智慧 その方々の中でも
智慧のランクの上の人が尊敬に値する
まだ悟りに開いてないんだけど
道徳は守っている それで道徳を守っているならば
もう礼をしなくちゃいけない
道徳の場合 またランクがありますね
比丘戒あって 沙弥戒があって
在家の戒律 五戒 八戒 十戒とかありますからね
五戒守っている在家は十戒守っている在家に礼をしなくちゃいかないんです
年は関係ないんです 例えば七十歳のおばあさんがいて
五戒は守っている おばあさんの孫は十戒守っている
おばあさんが礼をしなくちゃいけないんです
まあテーラワーダ世界はそうやっています
で まあ智慧も道徳ももうない場合は三番目に生まれ考えるんです
先に生まれた人は先輩です
解脱に達した方は聖者であり
断然目上なのです 悟りのランクは四つです
それで人が解脱に達したならば
もう無条件で聖者であって
断然目上なんです 聖者に達した人に対しては
人類みんな礼をしなくちゃいけないので
この礼の順番なんです
悟りにはまた四つランクありますから
この悟った方々の中でも上の方に礼をする
守る戒律 道徳によっても上下が成り立ちます
それ説明しました 道徳的に同じ場合は年齢で決めます
例えば 二人ともおばあちゃんも五戒守っていて
孫も五戒守っている場合は
まあ孫がおばあちゃんに礼をしなくちゃいけないんです
まあ簡単です 年齢が上がっても
年齢が上であっても 道徳を守らない
罪を犯す人は礼に尊敬に値しないんです
だから目上だからと年上だから言ってね
礼する必要ないんですよ
だらしない人間がもう放っておけと
それ一つの戒めなんです
俺が先輩だぞとか立場取ったって
もうろくな人間でなければね
誰が気にするのか あんたのことをと
性格悪いでしょうにと
悪いことばっかしやってるでしょうにと
先輩らしく振る舞わないでしょうにと
勝手にしなさいと いうことで
必ず年上の人に尊敬しなくちゃいけないかと仏教が聞いたら
答えはこれは分析的であると
分けて考えなさいと 性格が良ければ
年上であろうか下であろうか
自分より道徳的で智慧があって
性格が上なら その人に礼しなさいと
道徳的も年は平等だったら
年上の人に礼をしなさいと
たとえ年上であっても
相手がだらしない人間だったら
道徳を守っていないならば
もう礼する必要はないと
それから師弟関係はあります
これまた仏教はものすごく厳しくで
師匠にも必ず礼をしなくちゃいけないんです
これ アメリカ式はうまくいかないんです
日本もね その真似でね
もうハチャメチャになってますからね
もう教育現場は やっぱり教える側が慈しみを持って
憐れみを持って人々の面倒を見ているでしょう
いろんな苦労してますよ
教える場合は いろいろ苦労して我慢して
もう頑張ってますよ だからこの師匠を尊敬する場合は
学問はうまくいくんです
よく学べるんです 先生にもやる気が出てくるんです
もうすごい弟子のことはもう心配するんです
だから師弟関係はもう全く親子関係と同じなんですが
親子関係よりも大事にするんです
仏教の世界は 親子関係は親子関係だからね
もう産んだだけで 産んで育てただけで
それはもう簡単に切れるものでもないし
だからそこそこでも構わないんだけど
師弟関係はそんなもんじゃないんです
毎日気をつけなきゃ 追い出されればどうしますかね
だから師匠に愛されるように
ずっとそこで頑張らなくてはいけないんです
師を同格に扱ってはならないんです
はい ここで一旦休憩しましょうか
2番目の意味にそれから入ります
はい では始まります また
サンガに帰依することの 2番目の意味
僧に帰依するという言葉を忘れてください
仏法僧に帰依するというふうに
日本語で簡単に言うんですけど
これ仏法僧に帰依するではないんです
忘れてほしいんです サンガに帰依するんです
サンガっていうのは その並大抵のものじゃないんです
あれは個人ではないんです
悟りに達したというだけの話ですよ
それでもう個という存在が消えているんですね
出家比丘たちもサンガに帰依するんです
だから僧に帰依するってナンセンスやと思ったっても
私たちも僧に帰依していますよ
それはサンガに帰依しています
僧は先輩なので礼をするんです
在家の仏教の方々はお坊さんを見たら礼をするんです
お坊さんであることで先輩ですからね
出家した時点で在家の先輩格になります
出家するということは
いろんな束縛を捨てて
いろんな戒律を守って
いろんな約束事を守って
道徳を守ったりしなくちゃいけないんだから
その時点で在家より先輩になっちゃいますね
目上になってしまいますね
僧に僧に礼をしても その人から学ぶか指導を受けるかは話別です
礼をしたんだからって
あの この人から学んでもらわなくちゃとかね
これは話別です その資格がある人から学ぶんです
僧の方々 僧侶の方々の中で
資格のある能力のある人から教えてもらいますが
僧侶には対しては礼をする
目上ですから 教えられない人から教えてくださいったって
そのお坊さん困るでしょう
というわけで 僧の資格というテーマに入るんです
これは仏法と戒律で定めているんですね
で サンガの資格は悟りに達すること
サンガになる資格は それからお釈迦様の認定により
仮免許のサンガ組織も世の中にいるんです
その出家した人々 比丘たち
比丘尼たちには この資格っていうのは戒律と法によって定め
すべてお釈迦様の認定の世界だから
まだ悟ってないんだから
まだ修行中だからね で
いろいろ決まりやら教えやら
いろんなものを守らなくちゃいけないんです
僧にふさわしい 礼に値する
布施を受けるに値する人格者になることは
僧になってなった個人の責任です
それから 出家したその人の個人責任なんです
学ばなくてはいけない
修行しなくちゃいけない
心をじわじわと清らかにしなくちゃいけない
で その修行すると その人はまあふさわしい僧侶になるんです
で やらせることはできないんです
師匠にも  出家する場合は師匠がいるんですけど
まあ一般的にこの世界だよと
これは平等な世界だよ
真理の世界 ブッダの世界だよと
私もブッダの弟子で お前もブッダの弟子で
ブッダに従って生活しなさいと
知らないことだったら教えてあげますよ
それだけです 知らないことは全部教えてあげます
しかし もう出家した弟子にああしなさい
こうしなさいとか 何かどこかの訓練場みたいなところでね
ビシビシ育てるとかね
そんな義理はないんです
その個人責任なんです
人を騙すような生き方をすると
布施をもらうためにからくりをすると
その僧は罪を犯しているんです
いろんな方法で人の人気を買おうとするならば
その時点でその僧は悪行為しているんです
私が立派な坊主だとみんなに認めてもらうためにゆっくり歩きますよと
喋る時は戦場キャメラマンの言葉で喋りますよとか
そうやってからくりはやっちゃうと
ものすごいその人は罪を犯してます
どれほどお釈迦様に嫌われているのかと
お釈迦様はそれをうんこ食べてるんだよと
もうそれ以上の言葉はないでしょう
で それでもあんた食いたい
もう贅沢にお布施もらって生きたいならば
ご飯食べるよりは真っ赤に燃えている鉄の玉食っちゃえと
大したことないやと まあただまあ体の中燃えるだけやと
まあ地獄には落ちませんよと
それぐらいお釈迦様は厳しく非難しているんです
ですから からくりしてはいけない
ごまかしてはいけない
まやかしのことをやってはいけない
祈祷儀礼やってはいけない
祈祷をやってあげたら
最近の人々はよく乗ってくれますからね
どうせ仏教には力があるし
もうそれはもう だからもう大変危険です
だから我々も仏教を語ったり
祝福したりするんですけど
ものすごい気をつけて
それでやっているんです
皆のものをこちら持ち上げて祝福しますから
お布施をもっておいでくださいとかね
それはないんです 祝福してくださいと
もう頼まなくちゃあかんです
真面目に仏法僧敬愛して
真面目にお坊さんたちのことも心配して
仏教にすごいものすごい真剣に真面目にやっている人がいて
困っている場合は その場合は先輩だからあなたに祝福しますからと
まあ勝手にやりますよ
その時は だからその人
じゃああなたにお布施します
それはないんだからね
もともと仏教徒だから
同じ家族だからね 仏教徒っていうのは
みんな出家再起も一つの家族というふうに生活しなくちゃいかんですよ
自業自得なので 在家は困らなくてもよい
例えば あるお坊さんの性格が悪いとかね
無視してください あれは自業自得になりますからね
それにいちいち関わる必要ないんです
いい僧侶に 僧侶としてふさわしい人間になるか
自分で墓穴を掘るかっていうことは
まあ自分の責任です で
在家よりは地獄に落ちやすいんです
出家したら 戒律を守ることは基本ですね
出家したら戒律を守ることはもう当たり前
基本です 資格を失う基礎戒律は命かけてでも守る守るべきですと
一旦出家したら この戒律がありまして
これはもういかなる場合でも脅されても守らなくちゃいかんのです
で 詳細な戒律は阿羅漢にさえ完璧に守れませんので
まあ微妙な微妙なもう一億二千なんとかたくさん戒律はあるんですよ
で これはまあ知らん知らんうちに
小さな小さな戒律っていうのはね
まあ一つ例えば立って説法してはいけないんですよ
座ると立って説法しているでしょうに
で まあそういうふうないろいろきめ細かいものはありますけど
そんなのはまあもう破れてしまいますよ
で 定期的に懺悔をするんですね
出家は一つのコミュニティです
で 悟ってないかもしれませんだけど
出家もあの悟ったサンガのように
自我を捨てた我のない
一つのコミュニティとして生活しなくちゃいけないんです
いかなる場合も我を張ってはならないんです
で これまあ長い間我々は慣れたもんで
うまくいってるんです
コミュニティの繁栄と和合を目指す規則
規則もあります それからコミュニティとしても個人と関係ないんです
個人の修行は個人の戒律がありまして
みんなの和合と繁栄を考えて守らなくちゃいけない戒律もあります
それは戒律というよりは規則なんですね
自分がトイレに行ったら
トイレをきれいに掃除して出ていってくださいと
それは戒律といったってもね
それはみんなにと一つにしよう
しているんだから 次にトイレに入る人は気持ちよくトイレを使えるようにということで
で 自分の部屋の掃除は自分でやらなくちゃいけないとか
いろいろたくさんあります
そういうのはコミュニティとしての規則ですね
仏教は徹底した個人責任をの教えなので
コミュニティとして堕落することなく続いているので面白いんですよ
修行の場合は個人責任よと言っていて
しかし個は存在しないよと
一つの海の水のように生活しなさいと
これで見事なバランスをとっているんです
これはもうお釈迦様の智慧なんです
ということは 私は個人的に何か変なことをしちゃうと
どうなるかというと 堕落する個人が自動的にはみ出されます
サンガというコミュニティの中で
私は勝手に出ていろんな変なことをやっていると
自動的に仲間から反り出されて外に出されているんです
いわゆる仲間である資格は失っちゃいます
自動的に ですから サンガはいつでも何のことなく完璧に保たれます
あるお坊さん一人が何かやったんだからといって
サンガには何の問題もないんです
個人で責任持ちなさいよと
例えば あるお坊さんが賭け事をやって見つかったと
賭け事は戒律で禁止でしょ
サンガってだらしないんですよと
堕落してサンお坊さんは賭け事していますよとは言えません
それは本人の責任だから
それは自分で 何とかしなさいと
こちらには関係ないんだと
まあその場合はもうサンガはもういろいろ厳しい
あれこれあってね まあ言えますけど
もしあの規則戒律破ったらね
その時点で失格になっているんです
海が汚れを捨ててしまうようにって例えを使ってますね
いろんな川から水が入って海の水になる
もう差が消えちゃう それから海にいろいろ汚れもね
死体も現れますよ 海の中でも魚ね
死んだり でっかい魚死んだりしますね
クジラとか 海は全部捨てます
クジラがずっと海の中に生きているのに
死んだ時点でどっかに流されますね
だから海は常に綺麗なんです
サンガっていうコミュニティもそんなものなんです
それはお釈迦様の認定により
サンガと悟りに達したサンガはもう完璧
問題まるっきりないんですけどね
問題はこの認定サンガの場合なんですね
先輩後輩の関係は厳しいですが
サンガとして比丘は皆
断線平等です 先輩後輩
いつでもいつでも  1時間前に出家した人に私が礼をしなくちゃかんです
それはもう しかし サンガとしてみんな平等なんですね
それから資格っていうのは取るものかという
解脱を目指して出家するので
皆無条件でふさわしい出家にならなくてはいけないんです
それは無条件ですよ なんで出家したんですか？ということで
出家文章の中にちゃんと書いてますよ
今の出家は忘れているかどうか分かりませんだけど
一切の苦しみを乗り越えるために
サッブドゥッカニッサラニッバーナサッチカラナッターヤ
涅槃を体験するために出家いたし
出家お願いしますと だから出家する人が最初に口にすさむ文章なんです
それ忘れちゃったと言ったらね
ですから これ資格取るんじゃなくて
悟ったら資格でしょ？あ
資格取るぞと思った時点で間違いなんです
あなたの義務でしょうにと
そういう役目でしょうにと
能力のある人々は 修行して経験を得た方々は
慈しみを持って在家を指導しますが
わざとそのために学ぶことは醜い生き方だと言われるんです
ちょっと微妙なんですけど
出家は修行するの当たり前
戒律を守るのは当たり前
毎日良い人間になるために頑張るのは当たり前
その人が資格 いわゆる尊敬にふさわしいお坊さんです
だからといって じゃあ尊敬にふさわしい人間になってやろうと思ったら
それは勘違いです 出家する時点で解脱を目指して頑張りますということは無条件の条件なんです
この条件の場合も お釈迦様はずるいんですよ
この契約じゃないんです
一方的です 出家する人が一方的に条件を受けるんです
もし破ったら出ていけと
だから私が出家をお願いしますと言わなくちゃいけないんです
解脱に達するために 私は出家したいのですが
お願いしますと 頑張りますからお願いしますと
言うと サンガは頑張らないと
はい さようならと 頑張りなさいという義理さえないんです
そういうことで わざと資格を取るということではないんです
それでサンガの中で修行したり
勉強したりする人々の中で
人間というのは能力様々だから
結構見事にわかりやすく説法できる人もいるし
私みたいに何時間喋ってもわかってくれない人もいるし
すごく親切に瞑想を指導できるお坊さんもいるし
自分が瞑想はよくできてますけど
なかなか教えられない人もいるし
その中で能力あるお坊さんたちは
在家のことを在家の方々も一生懸命頑張っているし
出家を支えているし やっぱり助けてあげなくちゃいけないといって説法したりはするんです
そういうことで説法する説法師も自我をなくし
説法するんです 瞑想を指導するお坊さんたちも
自我をなくし 瞑想を指導するんです
はい 次に この三宝を冒涜するというテーマを考えてみましょう
サンケーは解脱の入り口なので
三宝を冒涜することは大罪になります
冒涜した時点で自分が解脱に背いたことになるんです
それほど不幸なことはないんです
だから 文字通りの宝物は三宝なんです
その門をくぐったら 究極の幸福があるんです
蹴ってやるそうと思ったら
だからもうこれはもうとんでもない罪になります
で 間違ってでも だって三密出家の中にありますよ
ちょっと冗談を笑わせようと思ってでも
三宝に何か一言葉言ったら
あなたはもう出家終わりと
その時点で原則ですと
すごい厳しいんです なせならば他に
その話を聞いて 悪の道を歩むはめになるんですよ
面白いんですよ 人間っていうのは
誰かの悪口を言うと みんな乗ってくるんですよ
特にお坊さんたちの悪口を言うと結構人気なんです
神父さんをとにかく褒め称えるんですね
テレビやら映画やらドラマやら
何でも神父野郎どもほどまあ聖なる人間ないように
あの人々は悪行以外以外何ともないんです
やってないんです 今 国で私の国を絶対的に国連で弾劾しようと頑張っているんです
もう恨んでる 平和はダメやと
武器売れませんだからね
それで映画ドラマになってくると
もう善人で いつでもお坊さん
日本のドラマでもお坊さんが出てくると
とんでもない何か悪役とかね
だらしないっていう風に
で そういうことがありまして
別に我々それに腹が立ってないんですけど
まあまあ勝手に自業自得
自得ですからね もう全然気にしてないんだけど
面白いんだから言うだけで
で あの 問題はそうやってお坊さんたちは批判しやすいし
逆に何も言わないでしょ
だから安全なんです だからって私を批判すると気をつけてください
もう答えがかなり重くなるんです
で まあ普通はお坊さんたちはもうもう何か言われたら黙って出ていくんで
だからいくらでも言われます
だからといって言ってはいけないんです
それは調子に乗っちゃうんですよ
そうすると他の人々もその同じことをして
この仏法僧に礼をする
敬をする 尊敬する気持ちがなくなるんです
それはその人に死後幸福になる道がなくなったということなんです
戒律条件として入れてはないが
出家も三宝を冒涜すると否定すると
その瞬間で出家資格も仏教徒であることも失うんです
でお坊さんたちの勘違いがあります
お坊さんたちはこの戒律上
項目をなんだかなんだか破らなきゃいいだろうと調子に乗ってますけど
そうじゃないんです 三宝を冒涜すると
まあ比丘は比丘でなくなっちゃうんです
その瞬間で だからそれからもう解脱に背を向いたんだからね
もう出家徒としている必要はなくなっちゃうんです
どころか 仏教徒という資格もなくなるんです
それはなんで戒律項目に入れてないかというと
もう当たり前 この仏教の世界では
お坊さんたちをバカにするんだけど
三宝にを冒涜することは誰もやらないんです
時々もう性格悪いお坊さんたちがいて
私はこの出家は嫌やとかね
信者さんの面倒見たり
そんなのやりたくないとかね
そういうことやりたくないと出ていくそうと還俗するそうと
仏法僧嫌いだとは絶対言わないんです
で 還俗する場合でも まあ大綿まではこれはまあすごい尊いお祭りとして一時出家して
それからものすごく丁寧にお坊さんたちから許可をいただいて還俗して
もう在家信者さんに戻るんですけど
それをすごくみんな喜んでやっている祭りなんです
仏法僧は信じません 嫌だと言って還俗するお坊さんというのは一人も存在しないんです
しかし テーラワーダ世界以外の人々はよく気をつけておかないと
西洋の方々も出家しちゃうし
これはもう我々のほど簡単じゃないんです
三宝に対してはものすごい尊敬の気持ちは必要なんで
これは 次やの この三宝冒涜は断言
もうダメです 仏教徒でなくても
三宝を冒涜すると もうかなり大罪になっているんです
あの この五逆罪とかね
もう 5つあります 仏教ありますね
母殺すこと 父殺すこと
阿羅漢を殺すことと ブッダのブッダに怪我させることとかね
それって出てあげますけど
またいろいろ調べると出てくるんですね
アマさんを犯すこと お釈迦様はもう絶対する罪は
まあダメやと もう直行で地獄に行きますよと
だからまあ出家は認めません
出家しても不可能だからね
まあせいぜい在家で五戒守る程度できますけど
次は決まってます そのリストにこれも入ります
三宝を冒涜することも
ブッダの教えを私は認めませんとか言うのはね
まあ構わない それはまあもともと仏教徒じゃないんだから
それは冒涜することになりません
例えばキリスト教の方はね
もう徹底的に仏教は間違ってますよとかね
やっぱりかもしれない
それはまあ それはその人の信仰ですからね
まあ大したことはないんですね
僧を批判するということはまた別格なんです
僧という言葉でサンガを意味する場合は
絶対批判してはならないんです
像と言ったら 自分の頭にサンガのイメージが出てきたならば
それはもう批判の対象にならないんです
サンガとは 聖者と修行する出家比丘たちのコミュニティです
個人の僧侶の問題が見つかったら
それを法に従って仏教の繁栄を念じて示すのは構わないんです
で スマナサーラがだらしない
悪いというのは構わないんです
まあただですまないと思いますけど
それはもう構わないんです
罪を犯ったことになりません
私の性格のだらしなさを見て
やっぱり僧侶っていうのはだらしないんだと言っちゃったらアウトです
全体的に言ってはいけません
スマナサーラのことを大嫌い
あの人の話も聞きたくないやとか言ったっても
それは個人の問題で 個人個人で話し合っちゃえばなんとかなります
その時でも根拠ない批判というのは
僧侶でなくても罪なんです
人を批判したりする場合は
根拠なく批判すると当然仏教では罪なんです
だから僧侶を批判して罪にならないんです
ちゃんと根拠があって批判したら
それは構わないんです
あんたやってることはブッダの教えに逆らっているでしょうにと
これはもう戒律で禁止しているのに
なんであんたやってるのかい？というのは
それは構わないということで
これは僧に限らず 我々人間を批判したり訴えたりする時でも
根拠なくやっちゃったら
これはもう当然ダメなんです
子供だからといって 蛇
王子 出家を軽んじてはならないとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
軽んじてはならない 子供がいるんだよと
一つは王子 王の王様の子供がいて
まだ子供でやんちゃで
なんだこの野郎とかね
絶対言ってはいけないんです
なぜかというと やがてまあ当時ではね
この人は王になるんだから
王になったらもう自分の親戚みんなまとめて殺す可能性あります
それから蛇 コブラとかね
子供って可愛いんですよ
コブラの卵から 出てすぐ
まあほんの細くて これぐらい長さで
あの十円玉よりも小さいカサあったりして
たったけど コブラの子供だろうと言ったら
噛まれたら毒は毒です
で こちらに火も入りますけど
忘れています 火も馬鹿にしてはいけません
それから出家している子供
あーこのこそ野郎とかね
気をつけた方がいいんです
もしかすると悟ってるかもしれません
悟っていなくたっても
真面目に戒律守って頑張ってる子かもしれません
気をつけた方がいいやと
もし悟りに達したならば
馬鹿にした時点で自分の悟りの道がドカンと閉めてるんです
法と戒律に合わせてみると
僧にふさわしくないと発見したならば
その僧を個人的に批判しても問題はありません
それはその人に注意する
警告することであるならば結構です
自業自得だと無視するのも安全な態度です
どうたっても自分の行為自分に来るんだから
もう自業自得やと 余計なことをね
やっぱり 例えば人が犯罪を起こしたと
まあこちらも構わない方がいいんですよ
もう警察に任せて 攻撃しようとかしない方がいいんです
世の中悪い人はいくらでもいますけど
こちらいて正義の味方になって裁くっていうのは
自分が罪を犯すことになるんです
悪いことをした人は まあ自動自得で自業自得で
どうぞご自由にと取ってくださいという態度を取るのは一個に構わないんです
その方が安全です 僧は皆悪いというのは暴言ですね
だからそれはもう言ってはいけない言葉ですね
客観性はありません スマナサーラが悪いというならば
いろんなデータ取れますよ
含む僧はみんな悪いと言っちゃうとデータ取れないんですね
いい加減な暴言なんですね
それは罪になるんです
例えば日本人が悪いと言っちゃうとどうですかね
日本人が悪い人を騙すのやと言ったらとんでもない言葉でしょう
あの 一太郎がいつは悪いんだと
あいつは私の金騙し取っちゃったと
とんでもないやつよと
それは構わないんです
もし私の10万円取っちゃったらね
嘘を言って その人の名前一太郎だったらね
まあそいつに対しても何言ったっても問題に
それでもって私はやっぱり日本人っていうのは人を騙すんだよと言ったら
これは暴言でしょ 証拠ないでしょ
で 僧侶の場合もどちらの場合も同じことですよ
それからサンガは衰退しないというポイントがあります
一切の現象は無常なので
まずはありえないことですが
サンガは末長く繁栄するんです
世の中で 組織の中でサンガほど寿命の長い組織はないんです
もう 2500 も飛んでます
そのままその組織が 戦争は起こるは
世界戦争起こるは 我々は今
最近もう 30 年間も西洋からくたくたやられましたし
で あれやこれやとか でもサンガ組織はなんのことなく続くんです
堕落はどんな組織よりも遅いんです
サンガ組織も堕落して衰退
衰退しなくちゃあかん
それは法則です すべて無常だから
しかし これが遅いんですよ
かなり リーダーは個人ではなく
法と戒律です そのポイントは
私たちのリーダーはなになにお坊さん
なになに大長老じゃないんです
私も入ってる組織の中で監修とかいるんだけど
リーダーじゃないんです
で 我々のリーダーは法と戒律なんです
ですから 法と戒律は変わらないでしょ
いつでも法と戒律に参照しながら自分が生きてなくちゃあかんです
だから 私の師匠が性格悪くたっても全然大丈夫です
私も性格悪くなるわけじゃないんです
私は法と戒律に参照して生活を直さなくちゃあかんです
それは決まりです だから
なかなかサンガ組織は衰退しづらいんですね
それは残念ながら別東教組織はわかっていないんです
で 腹が立ってるみたいんですけどね
かなり攻撃受けてますけど
失格者は自動的にはみ出される
だから私の生き方と法と戒律に参照したら
私はダメになったら私は一人ではないんです
ああ 一人でなくなっているんだと自分でわかるんだから
覚者がいなくなったら徐々に衰退します
それで あの認定サンガの中で悟りサンガではなくて
認定サンガの中で覚者がなくなると
例えば覚者がいる限り衰退しないんです
じゃあ覚者が消えちゃうと認定サンガでしょ
まだ修行中でしょ だからどんどんどんどん衰退し始めるんですね
そういうわけで 我々はサンガに帰依します
サンガっていうのは この上のない尊いあの働きなんですね
僧に礼儀礼をします 修行を応援します
協力します 僧たちに在家は協力しますし
応援しますし 礼もします
帰依はサンガにします
その僧侶もサンガに帰依します
いうことになって終わる終わります
はい これはサンガに帰依するということの意味なんです
以上です では どうもありがとうございます
それでは少し時間がございますので
質問のある方いらっしゃいましたらマイクを回しますので挙手されてください
はい 質問ある方で じゃあ一番後ろの男性の方ですね
どうも お久しぶりです
よくここに えーと えーと
話の中で えーと サーワカサンガと認定サンガと
あとビッグサンガという 3つのサンガがつく言葉があったと思いますけど
その関係についてもうちょっと詳しく教えていただけるとうれしくない
うん これすごい複雑 すごい複雑なんですね
サンガといえばあの聖者ということになっているし
で サーヴァカといえば弟子でしょうしね
で それでサーヴァカサンガといえば
出家も在家も入ります
出家も在家も一応頑張って
何だらかんだら悟りに第一悟りにでも達している
サーヴァカサンガ 比丘サンガといえば
出家しているサンガなんですね
そうすると 出家も悟りに達していなくてはいけないんですね
しかし 出家した時点で悟れるわけじゃないんですね
これはずっと修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
何十年かかるかわからない
それで出家したら どうせ仏教を学ばなくちゃあかんだから
道徳を学ばなくちゃあかんだから
瞑想に行く前に時間かかります
で 出家しているお坊さんたちみんなもサンガとして認めましょうという認める認定サンガなんですね
だから認定サンガは悟ってないんです
すごいややこしいんですよ
だから私はもう一つチャートを作ろうと思ったんですけど
時間間に合わなかったんです
アリーヤサンガという言葉があります
アリーヤサンガ サーヴァカサンガ
サンムティサンガ アリーヤサンガっていうのは
出家の場合 出家してアリーヤになった聖者になったサンガとサンムティサンガ
認定でサンガになった人々
それでサーヴァカ 弟子といえば比丘
お坊さんたち 尼さんたち
在家の男の方 女の方とまた 4 種類があるんです
どうやってまとめるんですかね
出家の男で比丘であろうが比丘尼であろうか
在家の男性であろうか女性であろうか
悟りに達しているならば
アリーヤサンガなんです
聖なるサンガなんです
帰依の対象になります
悟っていないならば 普通の上下関係で
礼をするんです で 出家の比丘尼と在家の男性女性ですね
男女の場合はどちらが目上かということは
お釈迦様はもうできるだけ無視してやろうかなと思ったみたいんですけど
なかなか女性はもう厳しいんだからね
もうお釈迦様は全然それは気にしなかったんですけど
問題はやっぱりこの世間には批判されますよと
だから女性は立場どうであっても
世間のことを考えて ちょっと一歩下げていなさいと
たとえ阿羅漢であってもね
本当はそれはお釈迦様がどうでもいいやと思っていたみたいですけど
世間の批判はね これはどうしても避けなくちゃいかんよと
なぜならば この批判が三宝の冒涜になっちゃいますから
お釈迦様の立場から お釈迦様の態度で人々は三宝を冒涜しちゃうと
これはまずいでしょう
だから三宝を冒涜 お釈迦様の原因ではさせないようにということを気をつけてみたいんですね
これは  ややこしくてわからないと思いますけど
それにまた新しいチャートを書かなくちゃいかんですね
じゃあ こうまとめてどうですかね
悟りに達した方々は聖者であり
他はみんなお釈迦様の弟子たちであり
弟子たちの中で出家した人々は認定サンガであり
それだけでしょう 悟りに達した場合は
出家も在家もサンガなんです
うん いわゆる帰依の対象です
男も女も全然関係ないんです
悟りに達しているならば
悟りに達していない場合は
出家在家で差が成り立ちますね
それで出家が認定サンガにしているんです
それだけです 在家はサンガとしてややこしい
在家が悟ったらサンガでサンガなんです
悟らなかったら仏教徒なんです
在家信者です だからウパーサカ
ウパーシカという言葉を使っているんです
ウパーサカ ウパーシカっていうのは男性と女性なんですけど
親鸞 親女ですね で 親鸞
親女が修行して悟ったら聖という文字が入っちゃうんです
アリアという そこで私たち僧侶たちが認定サンガだから結構力強いんですよ
力強いですが もう仏法僧の代表で
もう何でもできますけど
認定されてますから 認定を受けてますから
だからといって 悟った人の前ではもうどうにもならん
悟った人の前ではもう控えた方がいいんです
悟りはもう無条件で偉いんです
各者は 偉いんだけど その人々は言わないしね
自我をなくしてるし いるかいないかもわからないぐらい
もう大体存在感も消えるんですよ
だから気をつけましょうと
どんな人でもあまり馬鹿にしない方が無難やと
悟りに達した人々はあえて聖者ぶろうとはしないんですよ
だからかなりわかりにくいんです
はい そういうことでまとめますけど
あの 悟りに達した仏弟子たちは
アリアサンガ それからサーヴァカサンガとも言いますが
アリアサンガ聖なる 悟りに達していない人々は
出家はサーヴァカサンガ
在家は信徒ですね ウパーサカ
ウパーシカ 以上です  他に質問ある方いらっしゃいますか？では
向かって右側のこの男性
上げて手を挙げていただいてると上げておいていただいていいですか
前に持ってる方がいますね
一つお聞きしたいと思います
一番初めのこのテーマそのものなんですけども
サンガといった場合 日本ではどういった集団とか
あるいはグループをイメージすればいいんでしょう
あれは日本と関係なく
これお釈迦様 日本と関係なくお釈迦様の弟子のことなんです
我々の作るグループは人間のグループですから
それと関係ないと思いますよ
お釈迦様が定めた決まりによって
尊敬するか出家するか
そちらのサンガなんですね
お釈迦様は抜きにして存在しないんです
日本のお坊様方のことをもしかすると頭の中にあるかもしれませんだけど
これは厳しいことを言う羽目になっちゃいますけどね
言いたくはないし もう
で やっぱり尊敬しているならば
まあ仏教徒なんです もし阿弥陀さんやら大日如来やら
まあ存在もしない化け物を尊敬しているならば
さようならと で 勝手に作ったものを信仰したっても
正学者であるお釈迦様でない限りはもうアウトです
例えばマハーバイローチャナブッダをって勝手にしてくださいと
いうことで もうきつい言い方ですけど
どうしようもないんです
で いるんですよ あの 一般的にはいいお坊さんたち
日本のお坊さんたちは本当に性格はそんなに悪くないし
まあ立派な方々ですけど
その中でもブッダの教えはなんせあと日蓮の大事な教えあるのにお前はと
あの連中はもうもう残念です
もう先はないんです  ブッダの教えはもう認めますけど
まあ伝統として 文化として
自分のお寺では親鸞様も大事にしますよと
それはもう別に構わないんです
それはまあ 師匠と弟子の愛着であってね
だいたい師匠に対してはすごく愛着が生まれますから
師匠に愛着あるのはいいんだけど
偉大なる師匠はブッダという立場がもう変わらないんですね
だから日本では禅宗のお坊さんたちは
もう本質としてお釈迦様を尊敬してるんですね
だからその方々には尊敬はあります
たまたまブッダの教えよりは道元の教えの方が優れているという馬鹿がいるんだけど
私はその仲間と長い間いましたからね
まあそいつらはもうアホで決まってますけどね
他のお坊さんたちは 道元さんもありがたいんだけどと言いながら尊敬して座禅組んだり頑張ったりする
それはまあ私も同じ仲間やと思っちゃうんですね
そんなところなんです
はい  もう一人方手を挙げていらっしゃると思うんですけど
前のほうの女性の方  すいません
どうしても大乗 大乗仏教のことが頭にありますので
今の日本の仏教は檀家制度で
私たちもお布施をしたりして保っているんですが
その檀家が少なくなって衰退しているんですけれども
例えば小乗仏教の国ですと
そういう帰依という信仰
信奉に基づいたお布施とかで仏教は成り立っているんでしょうか
すいません 初歩的な質問で申し訳ありませんが
あの まず私たちにね 小乗仏教というのはどんな立場から言うんですかね
ただ ただ あのテーラワーダ仏教と日本の仏教は違うというような定説がありますので
その組織として違うのかということ
はい 違うところは 私たちにとってはこのお釈迦様とその教えと
お釈迦様の教えとお釈迦様に定められた戒律はもう絶対的なもので
もう立ち触ることはしない
もう変えようとしない
それにはもうみんな在家も出家も帰依して従って生活する
個人個人では足りしないところはいくらでもありますけど
一応理想として仏法僧に従いますというね
どの程度かということは
その個人の問題 学校に行ったら勉強しますと言っても
子供一人一人の能力によってどんな程度か決められますからね
はい そこはあるんだから
あの檀家制度はないわけじゃないんだけど
その厳しく区別されてないんですね
だいたい在家の方は出家を援助して
まあサポートしなくちゃいけないんだというだけのことでですね
それを代わりに出家が欠かせない存在として頑張っているんです
それはこの大乗とラベルを貼って小乗的なことをやっている日本では
だから中身が相同だから大丈夫とラベル貼らないと困るでしょ
だって北朝鮮はなんとか民主主義
なんだらかんだらでしょ
北朝鮮の名前は どこら辺民主主義ですかね
だから私はこの人がラベル貼っちゃうと泣きも反対ではないかとと思ってるんです
で まあ冗談は置いておいて
まあこの大乗仏教という組織では
このお釈迦様が絶対的大事ということは捨てたんですね
その時点でこの堕落した仏教宗派が現れたんですね
で なんで派閥になったかというと
テーラワーダがもうあんた方はもう自動派門でしょうにと
ブッダを否定したら もうはい
もうさようなら ともう仲間ではなくなったと
そこでそのグループは大きかったし
いろんな宗教の人々を集めていたんだから
で そこで大衆部というんですね
まずは この大衆部派が出てきて
そこからさらに堕落して
いろんな仏教が生まれてきたんですね
で なんで仏教というのはよくわからないんですよ
あれは学問的 正しくないんですね
親鸞教 日蓮教というべきところは
なんで仏教 仏教というのかよくわからないんです
親鸞の教えが絶対的だというならば
親鸞教でしょ それで構わないしね
それでその方々は この日本の政府制政治システムもありまして
この檀家さんということで法律的に束縛されちゃって
もう伝統文化に束縛されちゃって
もうもう依存しているんですけど
精神的な束縛はつながりがないでしょ
だから私は今ずっと日本で 30 年も喋ってますから
あなた方はもう次の世代に生き延びたければ
もう改良するのは今のうちやと
日本人が 私に檀家さん一人もないでしょう
でもちゃんと生きてますよ
ちゃんと生きてるし 時々何か用事があって
ちょっと金が必要になったと
ちょこっとでも漏れたら
すぐ誰かが持ってくるんですよ
だから気をつけて漏れないようにするんです
IPAD でも買いたいなとはちょっとでも漏れちゃうともう危ないんですね
だから今言ったのはもう買っているんだからね
で ということは 日本人が決して悪くはないんです
だから人間生きてる限り精神的な指導が必要なんです
困った時 助けになる人が必要なんです
失敗した時は教えてくれる人が必要です
子供が学校で暴れ回っちゃうとね
お前はね こうしなさい
こうしなさいと言う誰かが必要なんです
それが僧侶の仕事なんです
例えば俺 親に逆らっても僧侶には逆らわないんですよ
試しに日本の大乗仏教であっても
言うことを聞かない悪ガキ一人がいるとしたら
日本のお坊さんに会わせてみてください
逆らわない その時ははいはい
わかりましたと だから
そういう風に この人間に役に立つような
人間の幸福のために 心の安らぎのために
自分の責任を果たしちゃえば
何のこともないでしょうに
葬式一個一つもなくても大丈夫ですよ
逆に言えば そんなにも自分が生きることっていうのは大事なことかいと
私は何を食うのかい あれやこれ
私は全然気にしてないんです
だから日本のお坊さんたちも
まあそんな化石仏教ではなくて
生きてる生の仏教をやっちゃえばどうでしょうかと
私はまあ一応ボロクソに言うのは面白いながら言ってるだけで
日本でも一つ おばちゃんの間で人気ある漫才師がいるでしょ
もうむちゃくちゃ人を馬鹿にして笑い取って金持っていくんですから
何さんでしたっけ あれは
そう え？綾  綾小路  綾小路さん
で まああれほど上手じゃないんだけど
別に恨みは持ってるわけじゃないんです
素晴らしい人間やと思ってるんです
もうちょっと目を覚ましてほしいんです
化石に限りついているんじゃなくてね
だからこの日本人がお世話になったら
その分恩返しをする国民なんです
お世話になっているのに
逃げ 逃げる人間っていうのは
100万人に一人 二人ぐらいでしょうね
だから こんな立派な人間の中で生まれ育てたお坊さんたちが恩返ししないんですね
お寺守ればいいやと 葬式やればいいやと思っているんですね
当然 お坊さんたちの説法はみんな聞きたがらないと思いますけど
だって役に立たんでしょ？だって仏法ではないし
日蓮こう言った ああ言ったとかね
親鸞こう言った ああ言ったとか
役に立ちません それよりは禅の方々が言った言葉は役に立つでしょうに
なぞなぞで面白いし あれって思っちゃうしね
彼らが修行しているんですよ
だから信仰はない国ですけど
誰も宗教を問わず 禅道場にいて
時々瞑想とかやったりするんですよ
しかし 他の寺にはそんな自由には入れませんね
そういうわけで やっぱりブッダに戻るべきやと思います
それで国も繁栄するし
仏教も衰退しないし 仏教が衰退しないことは国民の人間のためになります
この戦争ばっかりしようと思っているこの世の中で
唯一真理を教えているのは仏教だけなんです
そういうことで まあなかなかね
もう私の考えは怪しいかもしれませんだけどね
テーラワーダではどうなっているのかという質問ですから
テーラワーダでは檀家制度があるといえばありますけど
もうそんなに厳しくないです
在家の方々は一般的にお坊さんたちの活動を支えるべきだと思っているんです
それだけです ですから
テーラワーダ世界ではお坊さんがいなくいなくなくなったら困るぞとみんな真面目に思ってるんですよ
どこが困るか私もわかりませんだけど
みんなお坊さんがいなくなったら困るよとかね
なんでその状況は日本でないんですかね
本当にみんな困るみたいですね
私たち見ただけでみんな喜んじゃって
もうあれやこれやと話しかけてきて
たまに悩み事を打ち明けたりとかね
悩み事なかったらただ世間話をしたりとかね
とにかく付き合いたいと思っているんですね
そこでお坊さんたちも結構冗談言ったり
人馬鹿にしたりするんだからね
これかなりストレスがなくなっちゃうし
だからこの一般の方々は
この組織がなくなったら困るという言えるぐらい
その組織が社会に貢献しなくちゃいけないんです
我々一人一人 人間があらゆるものを借りて借りて生きているんですよ
だから 人間としても人類に貢献するべき義務があるんです
みんなのおかげで生きているんだから
それは僧侶にとってはもうそれは仕事ですね
そこはまあ忘れなく忘れないならばもう大丈夫だと思います
はい  はい 他の方よろしいでしょうか
はい それではちょうどお時間となりましたので
最後に皆さんで回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思います
それでは合掌してください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に大拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティーヨーイワンジャントゥサンベローゴーイナッサトゥマーテーバワトワンタラーヨースキーディーガーイコーバワーバワトゥサッビャマンギランラッカ
ントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバブッダヌーバヴェーナサンバダンマヌーバヴェーナサッビャサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥテーアビワーダナシーリ
ッサニッチャンワッダパチャヤーイノチャッタールーダンマーワッダンティーヤーユワンノー スカンバラン
パーリパーリパーリ では長い時間どうもありがとうございました